let's get back to the all-star turnout
what could be Serena Williams final U.S
Open of course the goat dominated but
remember just three weeks ago she
announced that she is moving on from
tennis so the big question becomes could
Serena change her mind
[Applause]
a 23-time grand slam winner wants to
make it clear this next chapter is not a
retirement it's an evolution but it was
this question from a reporter that
really got fans wondering if we'll see
Serena back on the court will this
definitively be your final tournament
yeah I've been pretty vague about it
right yeah
um I'm gonna stay back because you never
know
either way Serena's going out in style
the 40 year old designed the figure
skating inspired dress that had six
layers to honor her past six titles at
the open and her Nikes were bedazzled
with 400 diamonds Twitter released a new
Emoji in our honor and last night Oprah
narrated a tribute video thank you for
never ever backing down do you still
have confidence in the decision because
watching you tonight we're thinking you
ain't ready either
what are you thinking Serena
um first of all thanks I didn't expect
any of this so um
[Applause]
yes the crowd was loud and filled with
stars including Anthony Anderson Rebel
Wilson Bella Hadid Queen Latifah Hugh
Jackman and Laverne Cox Twitter Miss
took LaVerne for Beyonce who's actually
on vacay in Croatia but Laverne is
loving it here
Serena says she's been trying for baby
number two Olympia who turns five on
Thursday was rocking a matching outfit
with her mom and those white beads are a
throwback to 19.99 when a 17 year old
Serena won her first U.S open I was so
happy when she had him on it's perfect
on her I'd look forward to just being a
mom she's such a good girl and I just
want to be a good mom to her foreign